okay here we are back
uh uh Richard this is for you is the
term toxic masculinity it's self-toxic
oh look at that curveball you got thrown
is the term toxic masculinity itself
toxic
yes why
what are we really talking about I think
is immature masculinity it's kind of
this acting out that you see among
anybody who's met teenage boys knows
that they have some growing up to do but
to label that kind of behavior as toxic
it suggests there's something
intrinsically wrong it's something that
can be exercised you know it's some sort
of right of exorcism if we could just
expunge that bit of you right you'd be
okay and that seems to me to push men
away all the evidence is that it doesn't
invite boys and men into the
conversation to talk about which bits of
them are toxic and which aren't it does
have that feel of original sin about it
how can we get that out of you and so it
pushes them away and I think what it
means it's a term now that frankly I
think has come to mean any kind of
behavior by men that the person using
the term disapproves of and once it's
that broadly defined it's lost all of
its usefulness yeah because it's not
just teenage boys that get accused like
that I mean that's right if it was just
that I don't know if it would be that
big issue and we expected from teenage
boys but I think you know there is you
know the issue of a much older acting
badly very badly in some cases
criminally right disrespectfully Etc and
should be held fully to account for all
of that right but the trouble with the
term toxic masculinity is now being
applied with such a broad Rush right
that it actually does capture everything
from really gracious criminal Behavior
to teenage boys making a list of girls
they find attractive or not and once a
time has been defined that broadly it's
useless and worse than useless it's
actually pushing boys and men away from
us and towards online figures who who at
least appear to be listening to them
yeah
um and isn't making a list of girls we
find attractive how effects Facebook
started
you're right it's not exactly here on
Facebook begin yeah reading them and and
who better than Mark Zuckerberg by the
way
the most socially awkward person in the
world
to have invented social media okay
Maggie based on all the times you
interviewed Trump what do you think a
second Trump term would look like
a lot like what 2020 would have looked
like had coveted not happened because he
was gearing up to put in place people at
the NSC who would do what he wanted he
was gearing up to put at the defense
department people who would uh do what
he wanted he was gearing up to put he
thinks everything is personnel and all
these people who were stopping him at
various other points in his term were
suddenly going to see their mirrors uh
you know gone and he was going to put in
people who would do his bidding I think
another Trump term would be a lot of
spite he still has to get people
confirmed by the Senate but if there's a
large majority in the Republican Senate
in 2024 after that election he's not
going to have that hard a time so it
will it will I hear he's going to
announce his next run quite soon very
soon yes is that that's accurate yes it
is it I I mean I've been saying all
along there's no way he's not running
again I mean he never really stopped he
hasn't do you think he'll get the
nomination of course I I think he is the
odds on favorite for it even if he gets
indicted which is a possibility oh
that'll only make him more popular and
it enhances his appeal with some people
he's the most narcissistic man in the
universe so what is more ego gratifying
than to be at the center of the world
stage yeah that's the main thing but he
also thinks that running gives him
insulation against an investigation and
that's a big piece of it right now he is
facing significant investigations yeah
justice department and in Georgia and he
thinks this only helps him but he'd run
okay I totally agree with you I think he
would run anyway oh he's and very likely
win and even if he doesn't like I said
you're aware of what I was saying there
it was an intriguing idea we have a
constitutional crisis in 20 24 because
either he wins or he claims he won
either way it's going to be a no you
know we're telling him no one's allowed
to say it's going to be a [ __ ] show but
it's going to be a short show
I don't know how you get it back
and it's hap you know it's not like we
haven't seen it happen in other
countries it's like that's what I was
saying it's like can't happen to us
that's what we said about 9 11 and
terrorism coming it can't happen to us
there's something to happen to other
people everything that happened to other
people it's gonna happen here too if you
don't well in all these institutions
that we think are going to save us you
know the Emerson has this great line
institutions are just lengthened Shadows
of people of men and women so if if
people stop behaving well if there's no
Brad refs and burger there's no magic
institution that stops you know this the
the election from being fraudulent well
yeah because the institutions did hold
before but will they continue they were
stressed but he's also told people that
part of why he's endorsed some of the
people he endorsed like Mehmet Oz in
Pennsylvania is that he believes that
Mehmet Oz would support him in a 2024
contested election that he would he
would approve of an election for Trump
and that he would not uh convict him in
the Senate if he were to win and then
get impeached again he's making
decisions with that kind of thing in
mind that's something people need to be
aware of okay Fareed is our primary
system broken would it be better to go
back to the days of party bosses
choosing the nominees well when you look
at who the primaries are selecting you
know people like like uh Herschel Walker
there's no no party bosses would ever
have selected Herschel Walker or
fetterman or well I think you know the
way to think about it is this
um we first of all we're the only
democracy basically in the world that
that has a primary system every other
place the party chooses and then you
have a real election so it's not like
people are not given a choice people
just don't have an election before they
have an election and what do we mean by
an election this is the crucial part
about 10 to 15 percent of registered
Republicans vote in that primary and the
same Democrats yeah so it's the most and
it's not a representative no these are
these These are the crazies extremists
and and and so what we we've done is
we've created a system where you
necessarily forced the political debate
to the extremes who were the party bus
we keep using this this phrase
smoke-filled rooms and party buses
because you know they both sound very
bad
um it is usually elected officials it
was Alderman Mayors seven Governors
these are people who had been elected by
the mainstream but but the general
public they had a good sense for who
would who would work with this is how
every European country picks you know
it's these
it's something we do at the conventions
super delegates is not what they call
them I mean that's what they are weaker
and weaker I mean so basically we've
made it so that the party is now in Hawk
to its most extreme 10 percent I mean
we've gone pretty much full circle from
where the founding fathers were yeah
which was they didn't even like parties
yeah and they certainly didn't like the
people
they keep it away from the people the
the clock racing mob rule that's what
they were mostly Madison said and Where
Angels government wouldn't be necessary
right the whole point of government is
to restrain the the you know inherently
well I'm sure everything will turn out
just great thank you very much everybody